[Musique]
c'est une découverte qui pourrait tout
changer
des chercheurs lillois de l'institut
pasteur ont identifié une molécule qui
serait capable de lutter efficacement
contre le coronavirus way pour
concentration maximale
il n'y a plus de virus il ya plus de
cellules en souffrance ce serait un
médicament comprend le plus tôt possible
dès qu on a confirmation qu'on ait
infecté par le virus
tu mets ton mal à te penches en arrière
et qui va avoir deux fessées c'est ta
dernière les problèmes sanitaires tout
le monde les rencontres
je suis du côté des restaurateurs quand
j'entends philippe escales et ce calèche
à bordeaux mais j'ai envie de le
rencontrer il a complètement raison pour
valérie si le virus ne va pas s'arrêter
à 22h cbs calais on va en parler baisse
esteves voilà c'est du problème c'est
dire que pour bonjour ont chantonné
bonjour c'est vrai il a lu alors c'est
quoi ça c'est un appareil à cake
ça commence mais fixe et j'écris pas
comme ça sur les jours c'est dégueulasse
ensuite qui me place ses crêpes dans un
moule c'est pas jamais fait avec ça donc
là on est complètement dans les neuf ans
le plus total alors nous à paris on dit
innovation team
moi je suis contre le paradigme du débat
contre le paris mou de la discussion je
pense que nous perdons notre temps
lorsque nous allions dans des chaînes
d'info à débattre avec les gens qui sont
de toute façon un conte vainqueur des
jeux assume totalement le fait qu'il
faut reproduire un certain nombre de
censure en vérité dans l'espace public
pour rétablir un espace où les opinions
juste prennent le pouvoir sur les
opinions et les diarrhées battre ne sert
à rien car il faut un sou retrait les
cerveaux france inter il a créé des
intervenants bien passé proche
voilà c'est la planète
bull à la force en ce qu'elle incarne
d'ailleurs meilleur j'ai été invité mais
vide apparaît formateur je n'ai jamais
été à jamais mais jamais elle ne le sera
pas alors jamais j'aille eric zemmour
nopus j'imagine alors nous avons des
paradigmes totalement irréconciliables
dans le monde que nous ne changeront
jamais le cerveau des dominants il va se
donner à fond il faut viser les jeunes
et pas les violets vieux c'est trop tard
selon nous c'est ça j'attendais ça va
mal et à placer tous les gens qui sont
ces nouveaux cerveaux m'a laissé les
jeunes c'est janvier les étudiants et
les lycéens et les collégiens la cigale
sept ans en juillet tout l'été se trouva
en pleine s
quand le froid l'a mis en pl ace pas un
seul petit somme or les chutes ni witz
t'es mort l affaire tiep chez la fourmi
au tchèque pour lui péta de la grosses
moules à belek frais registre en bourse
avant l'hiver miss kenya airs à l'aide
d'une partie spéciale dans son appareil
buccale il fertilise les ovules de la
femelle
[Musique]
mais la fourmi et quel show en vrai
c'est un gros char au c'était quoi tes
bail en été dit elle à l'autre fons des
recherches chez je me suis pas fait en
liège
rien que j'ai dansé balech à ce qu'ils
peuvent dans cette sartec maintenant
t'as qu'à chanter ou wesh
il joue à quoi c'est pas ça un poème il
faut parler comme à la préhistoire
les poètes c'était dans les années des
rois et dans les rois n'y avait pas de
voitures y avait pas d'autoroute jamais
les paroles tu as quoi comme voiture ces
mini capes
ni cabrio à bas madame pas mal ça
piquait pas été en correspondance avec
les attentes de notre fille a jusque et
traumatisé la victime se raccroche à
sont inoffensifs compagnon à quatre
pattes
mais rassurez vous êtes heureux en amour
globalement je suis très heureux dans la
vie oui tout va bien vraiment je suis
quelqu'un de très très joué je crois que
la vie j'ai envie de vous dire que non
c'est parce que je voulais m'insérer
éventuellement mais vous pourriez
revenir habiter à paris
quoi qu'elle en fait vivre mais qu'est
ce qu'ils veulent c'est difficilement
mangeable saganash d'une selle et les
granuleuse sous la langue c'est pas
terrible électrons sur écoute autant toi
tu es bien roulé ou ton gâteau lui pas
terrible à la question du bo c'est une
question passionnante
le beau c'est subjectif et je le vois
bien un regard de ma femme
c'est subjectif tu es très très belle le
regard il est il est fou ton sourire il
est ultra variété grammaire lacets et tu
es venu ici pour trouver l'amour pour
gagner le trophée du meilleur pâtissier
d'accord donc c'est un peu maladroit ou
sinon hors norme et ouais mais non pas
du tout pas non mais si tu veux je peux
pas être ta petite amie parce que je
suis prise quoi mais parfois je fait la
côte je peux compter sur moi pour
trouver la femme de sa vie bascule il
sort donc j'ai gardé l'amour de la
nature ça sera du comment maintenant
avec la sylve aux thérapies en fait vous
embrasser les arbres je leur fais un
gros câlin j'en profite pour saluer nos
amis les corses
j'avoue maintenant c'est une chose très
importante le dos on doit se préparer
pour sortir les badauds de la part
d'autres parce qu'en fait il ya des
travaux à côté et en fait ils ont fait
exploser une canalisation dévorer les
d'été qui sait comment la journée
mondiale des toilettes ont célébré la
journée mondiale des toilettes
ouais c'est vrai puis on en a besoin
après tout voilà
et quand même de là à faire une journée
mondiale j'y crois pas ça existe c'est
le 19 novembre c'est une journée qui
prône l'accès aux toilettes pour
trousses
nicolas doze et l'économie on va
supprimer la pub elle n'était là ou pas
apple nutella contre les voitures bam
trouve l'avion bam
or que fait un plan de relance hélas
cette balade a duré vraiment trop trop
longtemps
ça fait mal c'est une marque de pyjama
qui cherche des volontaires il suffit de
porter leurs produits pendant 10 heures
tout en restant bien assis
confortablement le volontaires
s'engagent à regarder au moins trois
épisodes de sa série préférée et à
regarder les réseaux sociaux sur son
smartphone pendant au moins 10 minutes
ça me semble être dans tes cordes sur
qualifié pour l'ol c'est payer 300 euros
soit 30 euros de l'heure c'est pas mal
amusez vous mangez beaucoup moi buvez
fumée et y ait plein d'amour maîtresse
jouissez de votre parce que c'est la
seule chose qui compte beaucoup plus
intéressant